good morning belief nation today's
message is belief over to you Casey nice
tat always made a living so I could make
movies I never made movies to try and
make a living but I think that's a big
mistake that a lot of newcomers do is
that they focus on how can my passion
paint and I think that's a terrible
place to start if the reason why you're
doing anything creative is to make a
living then you're doing it wrong you
get into it because it's a true passion
it's something you really believe in you
should want to do it to do it whatever
you're creating it should be because you
have a deep passion for what you're
making not just because you're trying to
make a lot of money I think a lot of
people make that mistake and people say
yes follow your passion but quickly that
passion could be jaded could be tilted
because you're trying to squeeze out
money and profit from it and that takes
you off onto another course well then
now you're not efficient by it you're
not excited by it anymore you're just
trying to make a buck well if you look
at the people who had the most success
who had insane amounts of revenue that's
come in but also an insane impact on the
world it's been because the reason they
got into it wasn't trying to make a lot
of money they would do it even if they
weren't getting paid and Oprah is famous
are saying that you know when she
discovered what she loved she would do
it even if she wasn't getting paid and
she would find part-time jobs she would
take two jobs on just to make ends meet
so she can continue doing what she was
doing it's so important I look at my
youtube channel you know I put an insane
amount of love into my youtube channel
right it's it's the biggest part of my
business life right now from making
videos from reviewing videos from
answering comments from thinking of new
ideas to put on from hiring my team it's
just an insane amount of time I love
that put into my channel and the goal
going in was never how am I gonna make
and money off my youtube channel and
because that's my intention because I
care about the purity of what I'm doing
I'm gonna end up making a lot of money
through the channel and that's where
there's a disconnect for a lot of people
because a lot of people will go in
thinking well if I'm making something
that my goal isn't money that I'm never
gonna be rich right and that's that's
not correct because I could cash out
early and a lot of people do right I
can't tell you how many offers I get
from companies and from affiliate
marketers and from you know people who
apps they want me to use but I've never
used and you want me to promote it I get
messages every single day from people
saying Evan can you please help me
market my app I will pay you X houses of
dollars to just say go out and buy this
app because it's great and I never do it
because everything that I recommend to
you guys is something that I actually
use and find value in right it's
something that I'm using in my day to
day life or I'm genuinely curious about
and that's how I maintain that
relationship with you and the second I
sell out and start promoting somebody's
app or promoting somebody's company
without ever being a customer or
actually finding value in it then I'm
gonna lose that trust with you and I'm
not gonna be here for the long term my
goal is always thinking about the bigger
picture where we're taking this the
movement that we're building the channel
is growing at an insane pace and I am
making money from it and I'm gonna win
the long game because everything that I
create is that a pure love and pure
passion so I encourage you guys to think
about do you love everything that you're
doing and how can you turn that into
something that you are making money with
but the money isn't the goal the money
is a way to keep doing what you're doing
and the money helps fund everything and
the second you start thinking how can I
make a ton more money just doing this
that's when you fall off path that's
when you limit your success that's when
you limit your upside and I get the need
to survive and survive it was important
but don't let it get to the point where
that is tainting and sacrificing the
quality and sacrificing your love for
the business and what you're doing
because people will notice they'll stop
buying and that's the end of your
successful company
believe so the question today today for
you guys is why do you do what you do
leave it in the comments below and I'm
gonna join a discussion thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso